thanks to babel for helping support this
episode
hey crazies just about everyone that's
heard of quantum mechanics has heard the
following phrase
the electron can be in multiple states
at the same time
but what if i told you that's a lie
quantum particles are never in multiple
states at the same time they're only
ever in one state it's just that most
quantum states don't make sense to us
[Music]
the quantum spin of an electron is the
quintessential example to use here but
that can get confusing real fast
it's like a ball that's spinning
except it isn't a ball
and it isn't spinning
so to keep this explanation as simple as
possible we're going to remove all that
baggage
like the photon we're going to be
traveling light
oh
[Music]
no electrons no quantum spin no none of
that stuff
we're talking about balls in the land of
make-believe
actually i probably don't want to say
balls a million times today
we're going to be talking about orbs in
the land of make-believe
these orbs come in two different
textures smooth and rough
but texture is on a spectrum measured by
the coefficient of friction i know but
this isn't the real universe it's a
metaphor just just go with it okay we'll
see where this goes thank you
these orbs are not stuck in their state
we could send a rough one through a
polisher and it would become smooth we
could send a smooth one through a
roughener and it would become rough so
if we wanted to we could change the
state of any of these orbs
generally though we're not trying to do
that but what if they're not just orbs
what if they're quantum orbs
you might imagine a third state that's
both smooth and rough at the same time
something we'd call a quantum
superposition
visuals like this are misleading though
for multiple reasons
first they give us the impression that
these new combination states are somehow
multiple states at the same time which
they're not
that's not how this works that's not how
any of this works
even quantum superpositions are single
states we might not intuitively
understand them but they're single
states nonetheless
second visuals like that make it seem
like there's only three states available
when there's actually an infinite number
of possible states
there are infinity minus two possible
examples of this kind of state it's not
the weird one these two are quantum
superpositions are the norm
to understand what's going on here we
need to do a little review of how
vectors work
if you're not familiar vectors are just
quantities that have a direction
they're usually represented as an arrow
like the velocity of this cookie let's
pause the animation for a moment and say
this cookie is traveling at 5 miles per
hour this way
if we impose an x-y plane on the picture
we can define a couple special vectors
one along the x-direction and one along
the y-direction these are what we call
basis vectors
because they're the basis of any vector
in the x-y plane surprisingly the name
makes sense
we can write any vector in the x y plane
as a combination of these two basis
vectors for the velocity that might be
three miles per hour to the right and
four miles per hour up
the set of all vectors that can be
written in terms of these basis vectors
is called a vector space
there are all kinds of vector spaces
some more abstract than others
see vectors are just a mathematical tool
and sometimes tools can be used in
unexpected ways
you know like opening a walnut with a
sledgehammer
anyway the coordinates we used for the
cookie measure location so we call it
position space
or since it's the default sometimes we
just call it space
it might be the only space you see in
introductory physics but there are
plenty of other options in my master's
thesis i used momentum space to model
electrons in a white dwarf but even
momentum is an obvious vector so it's
not too much of a stretch
quantum mechanics uses vector spaces on
things that aren't vectors
speaking of which let's get back to our
quantum orb
what if we chose one direction to be
smooth and the other direction to be
rough
instead of texture being on some kind of
linear spectrum like nerdclone suggested
earlier the texture state of our orb
would be a vector in this abstract
vector space
if it's in the smooth state it looks
like this if it's in the rough state it
looks like this
these two vectors are the basis vectors
for our texture space
they're also called the eigenstate
because whoa whoa i'm gonna stop you
right there that's a whole other video
we need to stay focused on the topic at
hand
what quantum mechanics does is it opens
up more options to a physical property
it takes the state of any quantum
particle and treats it like a vector in
an abstract vector space
any state of any particle
the length of a state vector is always
equal to one but the angle can change
that means many states are available to
it not just two
these are only the two basis states the
rest of them look like this
all infinity minus two of them
there's only ever one state arrow though
so it's only ever in one single state
to take this point home let's look back
at the velocity of our cookie from
earlier
it doesn't point along either axis so it
has components along both would you say
this cookie is in two different velocity
states at the same time
no of course not
it's in a single state 5 miles per hour
in whatever direction it's moving
another way to look at this is that
there's nothing special about this
particular xy plane i could have just as
easily drawn it like this or even like
this it doesn't matter if the
coordinates looked like this
the cookie's velocity is only along the
x direction did it suddenly drop from
multiple states to a single state no
it was in a single state the whole time
we're not changing anything about the
cookie itself just how we represent it
mathematically
the same goes for our texture states no
matter what states you're looking at
it's only one arrow it's always only one
single state
the fact that you can write it as the
sum of two other vectors doesn't change
anything the orb does not care
just a little note though before we move
forward
this notation i'm using is called
bracket notation as in bracket notation
each state is encased in a bracket when
the bracket is on the right they're
called ket vectors
there is a such thing as a bra vector
yes it's really called that but it isn't
important until we start taking
measurements
if we're going to continue like this
with our quantum orb at some point we're
going to want to measure that texture
you could feel it with your hand but
humans are a bit biased
plus remember that this is just a
metaphor for particles and you can't
feel particles with your hand
so instead we'll be using a texture
detector
say that three times fast texture
detector texture detector texture
detector if an orb is smooth it'll come
out one exit if it's rough it'll come
out the other exit so what happens if
one of those superposition orbs goes in
there
well how does that box work oh i have no
idea but it doesn't matter
wait where's nerd clone
a causation backup
i'm getting teamed up on now great
all that matters about this box is that
it sorts orbs into two distinct
categories and it never fails at its job
on the inside the box can work however
you'd like as long as it meets those
criteria so let's go through the options
we know the orbs can't split and come
out both exits my orbs are like
particles so they're invincible
invincible orbs invincible orbs
how is this still sounding like innuendo
anyway we also know they can't come out
neither exit because the detector never
fails that only leaves two options it
comes out exit one or it comes out exit
two
a superposition orb goes into the
detector and has to pick and exit
in the process though it's no longer in
a superposition
you remember how the polisher box could
make an orb smooth and the roughener box
could make an orb rough well the texture
detector can do either of those things
under the right conditions texture
detector texture detector texture
detector the act of measuring the state
of the orb
changes the state of the orb
and this isn't because we designed our
detector wrong or our technology is
limited
any detector that meets these criteria
has no choice but to affect the state of
whatever it's measuring it doesn't
matter how you design it
now to be clear neither the detectors
nor the orbs are making any kind of
conscious decision the choice is made by
physical rules
those rules just happen to be based on
probability
the state vector actually tells us what
those probabilities are and it does it
with these numbers this is where those
bra vectors come in
say you've got an orb in the smooth
state the chances of it coming out the
smooth exit should be 100 right
here's the smooth state written as a
vector
taking a measurement looks like this
a bra vector next to a ket vector to
make a full bracket
squaring the answer gives us the
probability which is one or one hundred
percent in this case
we can do the same thing with the rough
state
the chances of a rough orb coming out of
the rough exit is one or one hundred
percent
the chances of a rough orb coming out of
the smooth exit is zero percent
the same goes for a smooth orb and the
rough exit
as long as you can remember those four
options we can do this with
superpositions too
say the orb is in this state what are
the chances it'll come out the smooth
exit well you just use the smooth bra
like before
is it too much
it is what it is
what are you gonna do
the bra vector comes in operates on both
terms we plug in one or zero where
needed square the answer and bam
probability
you can do the same thing for the rough
exit or just subtract from 100
okay that's an acceptable analogy thank
you what's the point of superposition
again revere time
quantum mechanics opens up more options
to a physical property using vectors
rather than just smooth or rough our
made-up orb can be in any state in this
abstract x-y plane
no matter what it's always in one single
state we just don't intuitively
understand most of the options
the coefficients of a superposition tell
us the probabilities of getting one of
the basis states specifically after
passing through a detector that measures
those basis states that's it that's all
it is
and that's true no matter how many basis
states there are i kept my example at 2
for simplicity but it depends on the
circumstances you could easily have an
infinite number of basis states the
point is though if someone says a
quantum particle is in more than one
state at the same time they're either
not fully embracing the nature of
quantum mechanics or they don't think
you can
so did this help you understand quantum
superposition a little better let us
know in the comments thanks for liking
and sharing this video a special thanks
goes out to my generous patreon patrons
and youtube members like wacky who has
been pledging at the einsteinium level
for two and a half years
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
thanks again to babel for helping
support this episode
believe it or not i took two years of
german in high school but that was a
long time ago at this point i only
remember how to count and maybe a few
other words i'd really like to brush up
on my german for you know personal
satisfaction
babel seems like a really good service
for that the courses are divided into
short 10-minute lessons designed by
actual language teachers that means no
machine learning or ai real people are
behind how this works
but babel teaches more than just vocab
words it's real practical conversations
it teaches you about that language's
culture people history and more
my favorite part is that it's not just a
mobile app it works on your computer and
laptop too
if you're interested go to the link in
the description below
you'll get 65 percent off your first
language subscription it'll also let
babble know you heard about them from me
which helps out the channel
were so many people in the last video
saying they didn't want to get called in
the middle of the night first of all
they shouldn't be calling you without
texting to see if it's okay
at any time of day
secondly why isn't your phone on silent
at night i'm not about to get woken up
by a robocall anyway thanks for watching